let's not talk about that we talk about
eighth grade stop stealing our players
stop stealing our players that's all i'm
gonna say that's that um lebron james 34
points um he was 13 of 19 from the floor
he did all he could do
he just it didn't feel like he had
health and i got listen the reason why i
marvel over the others because if it
wasn't for my others i wouldn't have
four you was there you seen it yeah and
they always stepped up and now that you
one man is down a.d
somebody else got to step up i don't
listen russ is going to do what he does
now the a.d is gone but the other guys
that have to step up
everybody's killing you you're down
you're in seventh spot but every game
you have to improve so the others have
to step up one for third i'm not going
to bash them but one for 13 is not going
to get involved guess what those are
wide open shots
and a lot of times
others
at some point in their career
they weren't the other
so meaning
they
isaiah thomas was not another
he was the guy
so he could have moments for you that
you know even as he's getting older you
know
and those are the camelo was the guy he
wasn't another so
you're expecting one out of three nights
that these guys will be and be
them from past you know so they want to
you know
there's a saying that you know you
you're looking for either you're going
to be
uh
carmelo of old or just old carmelo or
you're going know you are you going to
become uh isaiah thomas of old or you're
just going to be old isaiah tom and
that's what you're not expecting and i
thought carmelo actually was
helping them and that was a big
difference because that third post-up
person i thought was a whole difference
well you know lebron carried the load in
the first half
right very efficient still efficient
throughout the whole game but he's not
going to be able to consistently do that
throughout the entire game so all of us
said i'm saying
that he was in trouble
that the lakers were in trouble going
into the second half and then you're
right when carmelo went out
i mean that's it and i'm gonna say it
again a.d defensively
okay a.d defensively covers up a lot of
the lakers mistakes and lack of
athleticism on the perimeter and when
you're not able to have that you're not
gonna be able to get out in transition
you're not gonna get open shots for
taylor horton tucker it's gonna be
contested as opposed to open shots
and the same thing i mean look at their
shooters across the board i mean trevor
ariza played well i like to see him get
more minutes you know what i knew my
others were special
rick game had a poor shooting game one
time and he came in and tore the locker
room up just tore it up let's see what's
going on i got to knock that down for
you big fella
he was like that he was like that big
shot bob was like that b shaw was like
that d scott was like that he's like man
if they go on w i got to be ready for
you before and
listen lebron's gonna be lebron he's
kicking out to you yes i'm not a shooter
but i'm not gonna go one for 13.
guarantee you that wide open nobody got
me i'm not gonna go one for 13. so he's
a better shooter tonight he's definitely
gonna need to step up
wait why why
that's three i yelled out
at the three-point line you're not gonna
go one for 13. well but first of all if
i miss four shots i'm gonna put it down
and go okay that okay
from the three-point line that's why i
was confused give me the ball give me
the ball
right now
okay that's all for one we're starting
right now
we're gonna we're gonna start right now
oh for one all right
no no no no
no no no
that was the pass that was about to go
okay
off the double go ahead there it is cash
out
we all around him right for two over two
we started over good
come on get in that's the pass that's
the pass oh for three boundary
that's the best
[Music]
oh it was better
that's a pass put your helmet on what's
that over seven oh
i was just messing with you okay
right here
falling yeah just messing with you
i was just lucky
i was just playing with joe
i said
how do you go from air baltic i set you
all up